bonjour jérôme rivière merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france les indicateurs en
ile-de-france qui sont dans le rouge
plus d'un millier de personnes en
réanimation et malgré tout le
gouvernement qui ne prévoit pas de
restriction pour la région écouter
jérôme salomon hier il s'est exprimé le
directeur général de la santé dit que le
confinement en ile-de-france n'est pas
d'actualité
le confinement de l'île de france n'est
pas d'actualité
l'ile-de-france est probablement la
région que nous surveillons le plus nous
mobilisons l'ensemble des lignes et des
personnels disponibles
nous sommes en très forte tension et
nous suivons la situation jour après
jour alors que c'est reparti pour un
trois week-ends de confinement pour
dunkerque comment est-ce que vous
expliquer cette différence de traitement
actuellement après maintenant un an de
lutte contre la pandémie de la cogip un
échec flagrant du gouvernement un double
échec
le premier il concerne les lits
d'hôpitaux on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
la difficulté elle n'est pas tant à la
circulation du virus qu'au fait comme
vous le disiez à l'instant que 70 % des
titres animations en ile-de-france sont
occupés
or on a aujourd'hui un peu moins de lits
qu'il y a un an en un an le gouvernement
d' emmanuel macron n'a rien fait n'a pas
créé un seul lit de d'hôpital
supplémentaire n'a pas prévu de faire
face à cette a7 à cette pandémie de la
façon la plus logique qu'il soit c'est à
dire d'être en capacité de traiter une
pandémie dans la dans la durée on voit
qu'on est aujourd'hui très inférieures à
l'allemagne je crois que les chiffres
seront sicile pour pour pour dix mille
personnes en france quand ces huit pour
10000 en allemagne et 13 pour 10 mai le
japon donc on voit le décalage la france
n'est pas une grande puissance de ce
point de vue là et l'autre élément
majeur c'est l'échec en matière de
vaccination nous sommes dont l'une au
dernier rang des pays de l'union
européenne et pourquoi parce qu emmanuel
macron par dogmatisme a souhaité faire
confiance totalement à l'union
européenne que l'union européenne n'a
pas su s'approvisionner on voit
aujourd'hui que les pays bas et le
royaume uni dont on nous expliquait
qu'avec le break 6 allait être un
désastre se trouve être le pays européen
qui fonctionne le meilleur matière de
l'acsi nation et on voit certains nombre
de pays
notamment à l'est de l'europe l'autriche
que ce soit la république tchèque
que ce soit la hongrie qui sont en train
de passer des contrats en direct pour
s'approvisionner en vaccins
parce que pour ceux qui souhaitent se
vacciner il est important qu'ils aient
des doses
il n'y a pas d'eau en france pour
atteindre les chiffres du dow qui ont
été présentés par jean castex ya
quelques jours qu'ils étaient déjà en
retrait de 30% par rapport au chiffre
qui avait présenté le président de la
république donc on voit que le au fur et
à mesure du temps il devient de plus en
plus modestes pour atteindre ces
chiffres il faudrait que d'ici fin août
nous vaccinerions tous les jours cinq
cent mille français etc ça n'est pas
possible ce week-end qui nous a été
présenté comme un immense succès la
vaccination a pris de l'ampleur
et bien ce week-end il ya eu un peu
moins de 600 mille personnes vaccinées
si ce n'est que le gouvernement pourra
atteindre ce chiffre a été obligée
d'inclure la journée de vendredi dans un
week-end donc c'est en plus d'une pure
opération de communication n'y a eu
aucune augmentation de la capacité de
vaccination en france l union européenne
et l agence européenne du médicament
vous avez parlé de de ces pays de l'est
qui ont adopté le pour certains le
fameux vaccin russe l'agencé européenne
du médicament elle s'est montré assez
critique vis-à-vis du vaccin on l'a vu
dans la première partie de cette
matinale alors que l'italie elle va le
produire même s'il n'est pas homologué
que pensez vous de cette politique menée
à bruxelles vis-à-vis du d'autres
vaccins en général
écoutez il ya un dogmatisme absolue à
bruxelles qui est d'abord ou ne veulent
pas reconnaître leur échec
oria on ya clairement un échec sur le
plan ii des contrats d'acquisition des
vaccins
les parlementaires que nous sommes n'ont
jamais pu avoir accès à la façon ni au
contrat ni aux conditions dans
lesquelles ils ont été vaccinées donc je
suis incapable de vous dire s'il ya eu
par exemple des conflits d'intérêts
entre les négociateurs de l'union
européenne et les laboratoires avec
lesquels on a contracté et par ailleurs
vous avez l'union européenne à un dogme
c'est quoi qu'il arrive c'est anti russe
et donc le aujourd'hui le levast
rythmique et v ous pout pout 5
qu'ils continuent et excusez moi qui
fait un actif qui qui qui est un un
succès en russie et qui est adoptée par
un certain nombre de pays
l'union européenne a bloqué les choses
pour que ce soit étudié le plus tard
possible par les différentes agences de
sécurité des médicaments en europe
c'est une hérésie on a besoin de
d'étudier toutes les solutions possibles
et la solution qui est proposée par par
la russie qui propose par ailleurs 50
millions de doses
si nous arrivons à contracter avec elle
est une solution à laquelle il faut
donner sa chance
le plus vite possible je crois qu'il ya
deux jours finalement l' agence
française de la sécurité du médicament a
finalement consenti à ouvrir le dossier
mais on voit qu'on traîne dans tous les
domaines c'est du dogmatisme vous savez
on gardera peut-être dans 1 à 100 de ce
qui se passe entre les médecins et les
pharmaciens le gouvernement pour masquer
son échec montrent des communautés
nationales les unes contre les autres en
ont parlé mais on va d'abord parlé de
jean castex qui était dans la nièvre
hier pour débloquer les premiers fonds
du secteur de la santé une enveloppe de
19 milliards pour l'hôpital public et
les ehpad
mais les ars garde tout pouvoir regarder
les ars donne à la fois toutes les
enveloppes et tous les leviers aux ars
c'est la première fois qu'elles auront
le pouvoir de décision sur tout le champ
sanitaire sur les ehpad et le numérique
la quasi totalité des décisions
relèveront du chant régionales alors il
ya de l'argent mais le fonctionnement
finalement ne va pas changer les agences
régionales de santé ont été vivement
critiquées vous en avez parler justement
par les médecins généralistes ces
derniers jours alors est ce que le
premier ministre a raison de garder
l'accent justement sur ces ars très
clairement pas du tout le seul
d'ailleurs pour lutter dans le cas d'une
pandémie
la seule autorité publique qui est
équipé pour faire face à des situations
d'urgence et le ministère de l'intérieur
donc on voit d'ailleurs que très vite au
moment de la lutte contre la pandémie
c'est plus les ars qui ont été mis au
premier rang mais qu'on l'aperçoit sur
vos images les préfets parce que ce sont
les préfets avec les maires qui sont les
mieux adaptées les mieux équipés pour
pouvoir faire face à des pandémies la rs
en fait c'est encore une fois ce dogme
de l'hôpital public qui doit
s'imposer face à toute autre médecine
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit libérale ou
privés c'est très grave
c'est très grave parce que c'est ce qui
nous a conduits à l'échec que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ce sont des
politiques publiques qui sont menées non
pas dans la proximité à l'écouté des
français à l'écouté des besoins des
collectivités méfaits sur des sur les
grands schémas qui aboutissent aux
échecs que nous avons et qui font
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes le seul
membre le seul pays membre du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies à ne pas
avoir développé un vaccin en solutions
nationales
c'est un c'est un déclassement de la
france considérable hier marine le pen a
présenté son plan en faveur de
l'écologie elle propose un contre
référendum à celui du gouvernement
un plan qui a été critiqué dans la
foulée par le garde des sceaux regardez
c'est parce que nous n'acceptons pas que
la démocratie soit réduite à des
manipulations d'opinion que nous
proposons ce projet de référendum
tout ça l'essentiel le bonheur d'être
français
bien sur son territoire bien dans son
environnement bien parmi les siens le
localisme c'est l'autarcie leur qui sur
soi la fermeture la xénophobie n'est
jamais très loin de tout ça ça commence
par le localisme ça finit par le racisme
ça commence par le localisme et ça finit
par le racisme à un commentaire écoutez
d'abord jusqu'à présenter marine le pen
son projet présidentiel
c'est une france qui soit avec de
l'espérance qui soit ouverte et on
puisse retrouver nos libertés c'est
important c'est ce qui compte pour nous
derrière vous avez ce grognon d'eric
dupond-moretti qui visiblement a pris le
temps de s'éloigner de sa télévision
puisqu'il nous a expliqué qu'il était
passionné par la série les marseillais
pour essayer de faire des rimes entre
localisme racisme on voit bien que sanaa
ça n'a aucun rapport
ce que je regrette c'est qu'aujourd'hui
alors qu'on vit une période d'extrême
violence en france où vous avez on le
voit dans l'actualité
hélas quotidienne d d d d d acte barbare
qui sont commis partout sur le
territoire où on voit et on constate que
la justice rend des décisions qui ne
sont pas appliquées
je fais référence notamment à ce qui
s'est passé à beauvais où une
un délinquant déjà condamné vingt-et-une
fois qui vient d'être condamnée à
nouveau à huit mois de prison n'a pas
été incarcéré à l'audience il n'y a pas
eu de demande de mandat de dépôt
tout ça c'est du domaine du garde des
sceaux et bien le garde des sceaux ne
s'occupe pas de la sécurité en france
je lui demande qu'il fasse son travail
il a été nommé garde des sceaux non pas
pour combattre politiquement le
rassemblement national ou toute autre
formation politique
il a été nommé pour s'occuper de la
justice et la justice pour qu'elle soit
pour qu'elles pour que les français
aient confiance en elle
il faut qu'elle soit exemplaire et
efficace elle n'est plus exemplaires on
le voit bien aujourd'hui l'état est fort
avec les honnêtes gens
il balaie il envoie des policiers pour
balayer les quais pour pour mettre des
verbaliser les gens qui sont dehors
au delà de 18 heures et elle est elle
est faible avec les délinquants revers
en est la halle le meilleur exemple
parlons de de la sécurité justement
puisqu'il ya eu une nouvelle rixe hier
soir entre bandes de jeunes cinq blessés
et cette fois c'était dans un quartier
bourgeois de la capitale que doit faire
le gouvernement selon vous alors que le
premier ministre réunit ses ministres
encore vendredi
il ya les deux aspects il ya l'aspect de
la répression
c'est à dire que le ministre de
l'intérieur doit donner instruction à
ses policiers de poursuivre jusqu'au
bout les délinquants parce que sont pas
des jeunes ce sont des délinquants il ya
toute une jeunesse en france qui n'est
pas délinquante
mais tous ces délinquants qui s'agitent
elles doivent être poursuivies et donc
cesser de donner l'instruction aux
policiers de reculer à chaque fois
qu'ils sont attaqués parce que les
images moi en tant que français et
parlementaire ça me blesse de voir des
policiers agressés reculer ils ont les
moyens de riposter mais ce sont des
instructions des ministres pour ne pas
un pur pour maintenir un semblant de
paix civile
donc ils achètent la paix civile par la
faiblesse c'est le premier aspect est le
deuxième ce sont les instructions du
garde des sceaux au parquet pour leur
dire que lorsqu'il ya des des jugements
sur des faits de cette nature il est
indispensable de faire des réquisitions
qui inclut un mandat de dépôt à
l'audience c'est à dire que lorsque la
justice prononce une condamnation de
prison ferme
il faut absolument que ce délinquant
haye
immédiatement en prison sinon il
retrouve retourne dans son quartier et
il vient un père aurait comme un comme
un coq fiable vaincu non seulement les
policiers mais qui a vaincu en plus le
système
comment est-ce que c'est perçu ces
violences de dd des adolescents en
france à bruxelles vous qui êtes député
européen écoutez vous avez raison de
dire des adolescents même des enfants
parce que à 14 ans ce sont ce sont des
enfants il ya une forme
d'incompréhension et stupéfaction face à
l'embrasement que vit la france
vous savez de loin parce que bruxelles
ça reste malgré tout ça n'est pas en
france ça n'est pas paris on a cette
image d'une france autour d'un état
puissant mais l'état s'est délité alors
emmanuel macron n'est pas n'est pas
celui qui a commencé mais il a en tout
cas accentuer cette absence d'autorité
de l'état
et souvenez-vous en 2017 au moment de la
campagne présidentielle
l'un des arguments employés pour
combattre la candidature de marine le
pen était de dire mais avec marine le
pen vous aurez le chaos ce qui s'impose
à tous les français c'est qu'on voit
maintenant qu'après quatre années d'un
mandat d' emmanuel macron la france vit
quotidiennement le chaos merci jérôme
rivière d'avoir répondu ce matin en
direct à nos questions sur leur
territoire